you want to talk about paid newsletters
really quick a topic that we've
discussed a lot
yeah let's do it but this one is
particularly interesting
um the reason why is we've talked about
this company a lot agora financial i've
brought it up to you a ton
they spun off a couple of their brands
and they tried to do a spack and when
they tried to do a spec the company that
they were spacking with
just like kind of like went down like
dropped like significantly
so they there was already a publicly
traded company that was going to buy
a few agora brands the stock went down
big time
but that's not that important what's
important is the numbers behind this
paid
newsletter business so there's this
company called um
actually i don't know what they call
this little it's a subsidiary of gordon
of agora i think they call it beacon
hill it owns
six sorry 12 different newsletter brands
collectively
those newsletter brands do
where did i put the number 550 million
dollars in revenue
and 200 million dollars in profit and by
the way growing some that grew 77
percent
over last year is that crazy now i'm
going to tell you all some more numbers
they have 10 million free subscribers so
kind of like the hustle that's like
they've got 10 million of that
uh this is even wilder they have 550
000 people paying them 600 between one
dollar and six hundred dollars
for subscribers then they have a quarter
of a million people paying them six
hundred dollars to five
thousand 000 and finally they have a
hundred
thousand people paying them more than
five grand for a product for a paid
newsletter
and what is in this paid newsletter
what's the what's here
here's where things get way crazier they
have some paid newsletters that cost
thirty five thousand dollars
now the reason why what gets crazy what
gets crazy with this
is that they have a hundred and sixty
products
across twelve brands so what's that math
so each each brand has
uh 12 12 or 13 uh products
and the products i don't even understand
but basically i
understand the business model the
business model as they get you to buy a
50 or 49
thing then they get you to buy a 2 000
thing
and they're and so they get you to buy
that 49 thing and that 49
thing is like a monthly paid newsletter
like it's not significant right
i don't understand how they get it to
work and a large percentage of those 49
people buy the 2 000 thing okay so but
i feel like okay so these must be b2b
newsletters right
no they're not uh yeah that's an
important part that i left out
nearly all of this is around and we'll
link to their deck so they have a whole
deck when they
they it's kind of scammy so they it's a
financial
and a wellness company which is kind of
weird they talk about health and they're
talking about wellness and if you click
agora up there sean
under my name you'll see the deck they
say that their their target
demographic is self-directed investors
what's that mean well i'm gonna tell you
if you're looking at the website it's
just a bunch of old
kind of wealthy white people who are
probably republican
and because the reason i think this is
they have ads that say like nancy pelosi
is coming for your guns you better
invest in these eight stocks
like they say like crazy [__] like that
right it's basically the like motley
fool
on uh you know steroids right
yes uh but i think motley fools ethical
these guys aren't they
also sold a book on how to cure diabetes
okay
i was gonna ask you why do you think
they're unethical and then you answered
my question
and so it's all financial news financial
newsletter
financial news related stock picks and
it's just just a crazy story i've
brought this up tons of time we don't
spend too much time on it but it's
pretty
wild to actually see these numbers i
actually guessed
that this is how big they were now we
have proof
yeah you've been talking about agora as
like you know doing hundreds of millions
of dollars and
you know some people know about them but
i would say most people don't know about
this empire
and most people i mean this blows away
most people's expectations of
you know paid newsletter right like oh
you know like i just had a paid
newsletter as an individual right i made
you know a few hundred thousand dollars
total and i thought i was crushing it
and these guys are making hundreds of
millions of dollars so when you look at
this
is my honest my honest reaction is dude
why couldn't you have done this with the
hustle why
what what did they do or what was that
why was the hill
too hard to climb where you could scale
like this because this is huge
i don't think it was too hard to scale i
think i could have done it
i would say that this business has been
around since the 70s
right so it's kicking ass now it didn't
always kick ass
if you're willing to be patient you can
do it second of all if you're willing to
put your ethics aside a little bit
it actually is quite easy to do it helps
so exactly
how would you do this you let's say you
want to be these guys or beat these guys
what does you know you're sam you're
probably one of the most well equipped
people in the world to do this how would
you have gone about it
well what you have to do is you've got
to create multiple brands under one
it's really hard to have one brand and
only a couple products make all this
money
so you'd have to have for us we would
have done and we were going to do this
but then we got bought and the reason i
got bought was a whole different reasons
which is basically i wanted to um
get a payday like and i wanted to i mean
like i was pretty clear about that
before like i wanted
like it was cool it was it's awesome i'm
gonna stay here but like it was nice to
like
get a lot of ticket um but if i wanted
to be patient
and do it for 50 years which
i kind of do to be honest um i would
have created trends but for subset
sub categories and you make the first
newsletter the one that people pay for
only like 49 or 50 bucks and we send you
just a couple things a month and then
the second thing is you go to sub
categories and you charge thousands of
dollars
for example if there was a newsletter
that
dissected media companies i work in the
media industry and you told me it was
four thousand dollars and i also got
access to a community
i ain't gonna complain about it right i
mean
i'm gonna do it if there's something for
digital streaming and that you know that
the five analysts are smart
twitch is gonna buy that it's not that
like challenging not that hard right
um and so that's what i would do from
multiple industries
and the thing that a lot of newsletter
writers do which i've talked about those
plenty of times and i don't have to talk
about too much is they do one of two
things
one they charge too little and two if
they charge too little they don't have a
higher end back
back product you need a front end and a
back end so you need your
cheap thing that gets a lot of people
and then you need your paid thing that
gets only a few people but it charges it
makes a lot of money so you guys at
trends is like i don't know 300
something a year you could have been
49 and then 5 000 would have been a
better
mix of value if you are if you were
optimizing for how do we get this thing
as
profitable as we can lucrative as you
can yeah and had we not gotten bought i
would have done that
i would actually we were about to change
it we were about to make that change
and by the way what happens to trends
now people still pay for it or it's free
now
um they pay for it we might lower the
price before we're either gonna
make that the back end or we're gonna
make that the front end but we were to
copy this model of
a 99 thing and then a 2 000 thing
yeah dude when i see companies like this
it just makes me want to
do it so badly uh because it's like
it just seems so doable now i know that
in practice when i and by the way
we get we get heat for this sometimes
because we're like dude it's so easy
it's so simple
we're talking like relatively like
building a successful business is hard
okay like it's not
just we're not saying we're not saying
things are easy sometimes we actually do
says that word easy really what we mean
is simple so
like being able to bench 500 pounds that
is
um um simple
like it's straight forward here's how
you get strong in the bench press you
lift a lot and then you eat a ton
now that is quite hard to do for five
years but that's
that was that's the steps you take so
it's like simple and so what we're
saying is that this is simple
it's not yeah actually i think weight
loss is actually a better example
because 500 pounds is a hard thing to
bench weight loss
is literally simple where it's like hey
you need to eat these you know avoid
carbs avoid sugars
you need to eat a little bit less less
calories than you're burning and like
you should
work out regularly do kind of whatever
just try to get an hour a day of you
know break a sweat if you actually just
did those two things
and be like hey give it like four to
five months six months
boom you're in great shape everybody
knows that formula it is actually
simple executing it and doing it having
the discipline and having the rigor to
like actually stick to it
hard but it is way easier
relatively than becoming a crossfit
champion right and so when we're talking
about business
the scale is that it's like it's hard to
create the next facebook
that's really freaking hard uh is it
hard to create a paid community well
i don't think most people who try it
will do it but it's relatively way
easier than creating the next facebook
so
for people that out there that get all
sensitive when we call something easy
it's not we're not trying to mislead you
like yeah it's gonna take work most
likely it won't work it'll take some
time
but we're on a scale of one to spacex
this is more like a one than it is a
spacex and like that's a that's a scale
for for people to think about
i completely agree and um i think like
now let's talk about what makes this
hard the first and
is that you have to sell your soul a
little bit now
many people will not be comfortable with
this stuff sean is pretty comfortable
with it i think i'm
comfortable with it but i think i'm a
little bit less comfortable with it you
have to be a face
sometimes you have to be you have to say
i'm an expert
at x pay me money to for me to tell you
my thoughts
right second um well no this is off that
so guys like james altucher who we've
had this podcast he was ridiculed for
doing this with bitcoin everyone made
fun of him
he made 60 million dollars doing it but
he still got mocked constantly and
shockingly most people would actually
prefer
not to make the money and not get made
fun of than they would to make the money
and get made fun of well the way i think
about it is
most people truly will not they're
afraid that they're going to get them
not going to get the money and get
mocked and so they're like [__] it i
won't do it
if you really had a guarantee i think
people would happily
trade reputation points for bank points
yeah and perhaps but that's some moot
point because the fact is is that most
people don't even want to
because the first point you said of like
they may not get the money at all that
is also true
and that's what they're they're not
going to do that so you have to do that
second
it's a treadmill you can't stop this is
a lifetime
job so if you're a content creator you i
hired people to do it for me you 100
can do that but you're gonna you can't
you have to you actually have to do the
work for a little while
in the anyway so you're gonna have to
work and by the way uh
quick question on hiring because people
ask me this and i have no idea i'm like
why don't you ask sam
he's the one who did it why are you
asking me they'll be like dude the
hustle has had
amazing talent like they talk about
trung they talk about steph smith
they think about some of the people you
guys you me i mean right i mean i
consider
you be part of our crew you me trung
steph this guy colby we've got yeah
we've got a bunch of people so the
question is
where the heck did you find these people
so can you give me the
10 seconds on each where'd you find
chuang where'd you find steph where'd
you find colby where'd you find
you know all these people colby was
worked at a pr firm where he was doing
some copywriting work
uh and uh trung uh amen
did he just apply to you or you like
recognize like oh this guy's good mutual
connection friend of a friend
said you should talk to this person uh
trung came from eamon troy a mutual
friend and investor of the hustle
steph uh i found on twitter because i
read her blog
who else that's it i just kind of want
to know and then when you found these
people
are you what's your did you cycle
through 30 people who kind of
sort of saw before you found the gems
when we actually sold
to hubspot they were like wow you guys
have a lot of churn i'm like yeah but
here's what we do
like this is actually quite normal in
the editorial industry but you hire a
bunch of people and you've
got a you you either fire or there's a
mutual like all right we tried it it
wouldn't fit
um and that happens a lot um yeah
and you also when you understand the
tone i would say that was also a key
right because you were writing it
originally
and so you yeah and you called the
translated the right people
you saw the trends community like i was
the one actually doing it before
every day you were posting in that thing
yeah and that sets the culture and
attracts like-minded people um i also
think that um
once you find the winners then you go
all in on them so trung
is what i call he's a made man steph a
made woman
whatever steph wants to do something
cool sounds good
what do you need uh when other people
come to me with an idea
negotiate baby trying to time to double
it trying to double that number
whatever's number sam gave you time to
double it
these guys are all doing great um
whenever
if an outside person or if a non-main
person comes with an idea
it's you know why don't you just show me
a little mvp
and let's see what people think right
trunk says something it's
all right yes sir right yeah like you're
a proven hitmaker so
and then the um the last thing is when
we interview them i always ask about the
bottom fourth of the resume
which is like the college classes and
all the things that they take because i
want them to like entertain me during
the interview
so in the same way that you are really
good at storytelling you have to have
other people that are good storytelling
right right
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no
travel never looking back